I was a bit nervous um I gotta be honest
I saw Pierce's um first interview with
Andrew Tate and you know I'm being
labeled the female version of Andrew
Tate so I was like oh no please and
again I have one day to prepare and I'm
thinking dear God please let me have a
woman card please let me have a woman
card I'm the female Andrew Tate please
do not talk to me like a man and lo and
bold lo and behold when I went on he was
he was perfectly nice they stuck to the
topic about feminism which is one that I
really enjoy talking about and yeah so I
had about a day to prepare we went over
some talking points I was told to be 10
to 12 minutes they had me on with
another girl and I I had a great time